good to see you
nice to see you uh let me start by
saying congrats on the movie um i'm sure
you're hearing this from everyone but
it's so well done and you're so
excellent in this in these roles if you
will i just want to give you props
um thank you i like i like throwing a
curveball as my first question and so
i promise it's soft okay all right
if someone got a lot playing ball when i
was in high school so let's see how i do
if someone has never seen anything that
you've done what's the first thing you
want them watching and why
oh wow oh
that is a great question wow
and i'm sure whatever answer i give you
i would want to change it as soon as we
got off i guess i would say
oh man
i guess i would say true detective i
guess
i guess just
i don't know i don't know that's a
really good question
moonlight i would say moonlight i would
say moonlight you know i think that the
one i feel great about my part in it
but i just think that the movie is just
phenomenal and timeless and all the
performances but i feel like there's
there's um
there's an essence there that i i feel
very connected to just with that
character
you know that i that i do think reflects
something about me as well but um but i
guess i would say moonlight
uh yeah you have an abundance to choose
from it's actually it's you know it's i
can i understand why you would delete a
battle angel there you go
so one of the things that i love about
this script um is that there's no stupid
characters trying to get the technology
or
you know dumb exposition or it's just so
about what makes us human and the moral
implications of of this decision yeah
can you sort of talk about just the
smart script
yes everything is
ben wanted everything to feel organic
he didn't want the film to get
swallowed by
the
mustache twisting sort of like sci-fi
elements that you would usually see in
some sort of clone story like this is
this is different from that this is more
about
cameron's own internal struggle to trust
this process
this
this opportunity which is like clearly
unprecedented he's like the third person
to ever
even have an opportunity to do this so
he's constantly questioning how much to
trust this
and i think as he learns
a little bit more about
about jack and this process and and is
somewhat more at
at ease i think at the same time it
becomes a little bit other emotions
begin to pop up
from
jealousy to
you know just wanting to be able to
control his own narrative to to
to be able to to know his ending and for
other people his family to be able to to
consciously experience that with him so
he he's constantly wrestling with a
world of emotions but it never gets into
some nefarious thing per se it's really
just about
cameron finding his own piece
uh with this process and it's a real
struggle and for
a lot of reasons that would be i think
pretty clear and obvious to all of us
upon seeing the film
um one of the things i love this near
sci-fi if you will like stuff that we
know
at some point in the not so distant
future we're all going to be grasping
with maybe not us but the generation
after us who knows um so i mean have you
when making this film did you have a lot
of that internal
debate of would i actually do this
you know like can you sort of talk about
your own struggles that you maybe
you know thought about yeah
um
you know the the beautiful thing is that
the job itself was so immersive that i
didn't have a lot of time to think about
myself
which is so freeing as an actor you know
um
but when i but in moments when i have
asked myself that question
i i had to again go back to cameron's
life and look at
his issues the context of of of the
story and his own life and the things
that his
poppy played by the wonderful naomi
harris the things that she had gone
through as a character and looking at
what their their family makeup is they
have a 10 year old and then they have a
child on the way
and so someone dealing with the terminal
illness and having seen
his wife navigate depression off of from
losing her twin brother you know um
they were all things that i think
contributed to
making an extraordinarily difficult
decision
a little bit easier for for someone like
that and so
for me considering i don't have all that
going on in my life but i but i do
i do have a wonderful child and a
wonderful wife
i i still feel like i
i have to
sort of lean towards the side of
of respecting the
the story of life the beginning middle
and end and end
and trying to just
live as fully as possible for as long as
i have i lost my father he was 38 years
old and i remember thinking
some years shortly after
that like wow he was 38 but he felt so
much older because he lived such a full
life and i've never really forgotten
that you know and i try to be as
present as possible with people you know
and i think it's something that we're
all really sensitive to right now
because of
of our world
experiencing
a heightened degree of death and all of
us being a degree of separation
from people who have gone who have
we feel like they've died too soon you
know
um so i i think if anything i just move
the focus towards being as present
and as open and as loving and as hopeful
as possible
right now in the in every moment that i
have you know and
and life is going to to take its course
but i so appreciate
the question that the film poses and
what did it what it
what it causes and triggers all of us to
think about
last last i've just got the wrap but
just real quick i'm obviously overjoyed
that you're going to be playing blade as
you can tell maybe behind me i'm a
little bit of a fan
um i just i just want to know um like
when do you actually have when are you
guys actually filming the movie and what
are you most excited for fans to see i
i'm ex i'm excited for
i i appreciate everyone's excitement
and i appreciate the anticipation
i got a lot of work to do and i and i i
look forward to us filming when we get
going and i i want to earn it i just
that's all i want to say i want to earn
it and so i'm i'm working on earning it
right now
on that note um i'm just going to say
man again great work in this thank you
for giving me your time and good luck
with the rest of your interview
thank you